les scouts et guides de france traverse
leur époque sans la moindre ride
peut-être parce que le silence leur
permet de mieux se fondre dans la nature
soixante ans de rencontres d'activités
de plein air dans le but d'harmoniser le
développement des caractères et de se
comprendre par la seule technique de
l'adaptation
pas de notes reviennent dans ces
rencontres chacun compte sur lui et
vient aider l'autre c'est instinctif
retrouver un langage avec un
environnement qui n'a pas subi et
manipulation de la civilisation s'est
trouvé les rites de l'apprentissage pour
une nature souvent perfectible qui
montrent qu'elle est peut-être aussi
l'image de dieu image qui sera de ciment
de ces deux journées le premier but
c'est de commémorer l'anniversaire le
soixantenaire de la création des scouts
dans le loiret qui dit être à l'époque
une un événement c'est aussi l'occasion
pour les scouts et les guides de
maintenant de montrer qu'ils sont
capables en peu de temps de monter une
opération est de vivre ensemble deux
jours alors aujourd'hui le thème et la
construction de mon nouveau ça veut dire
quoi monde nouveau un monde nouveau
c'est un monde à construire dans lequel
il faudra surtout bon vigneron et le but
c'est ducati de notre mouvement c'est de
montrer aux enfants que ce monde est
toujours à construire